angela until you and michael can be
together what's next for the both of you
oh god
yeah spill the beans
up in front of michael angela
is about to make a drastic change to her
life
and michael he's not happy about it
no no no no no no no
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisa
part three of the tell-all officially
marked the
end of happily ever after season five
and it included some major reveals
one of them was just announcing that her
new man
put a ring on it who is this guy jess
is he there with you yeah can we meet
him
[Music]
you'll get to see him and learn how it
all happened
in just a few but first let's talk about
angela telling michael for the first
time
that she's getting weight loss surgery
in a few weeks
you're getting weight loss surgery yes
wow after the third month i'll drop
about a hundred and something pounds
wow my everything will be reconstructed
my skin surgery they'll do it i'm going
to have it all done
michael you did not know this
no she knows i don't like anything soju
like
no doing all this artificial stuff i
don't like it
but i don't like it michael i it's
annoying to be out of breath
when you know you've gained 20 pounds
and two months from sitting
around here eating everything the kids
eat angela has been vocal
about how dating a younger man has made
her more insecure about her body
but during the tell-all michael kept
trying to reassure her
that he actually prefers her size
that don't complain about your body i
don't complain you know this
i didn't complain but you gotta feel
sexy to be sexy
right and if you know i've never like uh
to feel fat or anything i like big
cheese i like you the way you are i like
greetings you notice
so why we have great sex now michael but
can you imagine 100 pounds off i'll flip
you upside down
yeah angela
too much information all right well all
jokes aside
this is a very serious surgery even
larissa
chimed in and reminded her of the rest
gonna look one million bucks
but you can't die any kind of surgery is
a risk
but say this risk worth it to you versus
michael's wish oh yeah
well michael's also wishing for
a baby so my first thought
was could this weight loss surgery money
go towards
adoption or even ivf
how are we going to have time to do
anything with my age that i can do it
now with you
climb rounds go to beaches go to new
york go all over the world
how are we going to do that we can't
afford it because we're putting money
into our ivf and then when we get done
it might not take and then i'm 62
and i can't go nowhere and do nothing
because i'm too old
i mean angela you're saying that michael
is going back and forth flip-flopping
but i feel like right
now you're the one doing the
flip-flopping i mean either you want to
give michael a child or you do all
within your power
to do that or you don't colt made a good
point
of course spend your money how you
please
but this weight loss surgery move does
make you think that angela doesn't plan
to go through with
giving michael the child he so
desperately wants
i want to do this for me
okay all right well moving on to
jess and this new mystery man
look mayuki grades there we go
okay
ryan he said the man supports me
make me happy every single day
help me a lot make me happy love me
is loyal don't lie is there nothing i
need to talk with a lot of women so i
feel better
he just needs me so basically she's
trying to say he's
not like colt well after she was done
hyping brian up
she told everyone the big news
mary emma
yeah she got her green cards
jess you did it i have yeah man
and you're going to support me that's
too much better than just green cards
with you
and your green card congratulations i'm
very happy thank you so much
i'm very happy too yeah i'm happy for
the newlyweds and their new green curve
colt must still care because he is
definitely throwing
a lot of shade jess could really be into
this guy
or she just did what she felt she needed
to do
and he was all for it the situation all
together is
a bit odd and it has an even
weirder twist larissa colt's ex-wife
played a part in jess colt's
ex-girlfriend
finding her new husband
yeah okay so tell me this how did you
well i'm starting out with florissa
larry's introduced coming to me
and will come and start talking every
day and she said jess
i think she needs to try dates again
because you're so pretty so nice
she said i have a friend he's vegetarian
like the same music with you
and i think perfect match and maybe
brian start talk
so wait basically larissa is responsible
for you and brian meeting through her
friend carmen
yes interesting right well
they started dating about five months
after colt
and jess broke things off and according
to brian
it was his idea to get married so
quickly
i had to rush it because she lost her
job
so i thought the best thing to do is to
marry her
it's like make sure we can keep growing
our relationship yeah
so i thought if i go come back to brazil
and he said no
i know i want to lose you i need you
here with me
and he's safe gonna marry
and they say yes just says brian
didn't want to do a long distance
relationship
so the two tied the knot after three
weeks
of dating do you think that you guys
have known each other
long enough to know that this is the
relationship for both of you
i think so i think we've been talking
like
it's faster than i want it to be for the
connection i have with her something i
haven't felt like ever
and i really don't want to lose it bryce
so sweetheart
he's so nice your family is so nice
someone's so sweet
and now i find my true love
these two are either okay actors
or they're serious i don't know
i guess time will tell there was one
thing
that was clearly obvious and that's the
fact that colt
was a bit bitter about the situation
colt um parting words do you have any
advice for brian
uh no advice but i will say one thing i
must be the luckiest
man alive because i dodge both these
women and i'm
i'm free so i'm very happy
i'm glad you messed up with jones
because i'm pretty happy too
good response brian okay so
now he's either a great actor
or he's serious all right 90 day fans
fam
that does it for the three-part tell-off
special
i had so much fun bringing you all of
the must-see moments
make sure you stick with et to stay
updated on all the latest news
from the 90 day universe alright i'll
see you next time
you